dude wait you guys got a podcast for a
second
i i just looked at my camera
and the record light was blinking the
whole time and my card has been full for
like 20 minutes so oh good yeah so my
footage will be webcam only i'll be
right back i'm going to grab a cf card
um let's talk about the shooting and you
know break that down
yeah yeah we have that in the agenda
anyways we're gonna spend the last 20
minutes just talking about that super in
depth so um what what have you been what
have you been thinking about
what's new not too much man uh i've been
feeling awfully nostalgic these days so
i've been thinking about like
re-watching some of my old favorite
shows like guerin lagann if you've ever
seen that anime started re-watching a
little courage the cowardly dog again
like just feeling real nostalgic was
gonna bust out gears of war pretty soon
which is oh my god see yeah now that's a
game i actually did play
you were a big gears guy back in the
yeah the 06 era oh yeah i played it
every single day for hours and hours
only online though say did you do the
sniper battles or were you a ranked only
kind of guy wait were you playing on
xbox or what were you playing on i was
playing xbox uh no i never did sniper
battles i did ranked only oh yeah sniper
battles were big in my circle on gears
of war you'd go on canals sniper only oh
yeah oh it was so fun actually i did do
that a couple times
but i was never a really good sniper uh
that's where i started i used to make
little sniper montages and 1v1s with
people set to like extreme metal music
and stuff
that was my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it was so good there's still nothing
like it no well we're just talking about
final fantasy yeah yeah yeah clearly
yeah yeah dude i i i didn't i never i
skipped the whole xbox era i never are
you [ __ ] up i know well i was working
like bozo ass jobs it sounds like it
built character put some hair on your
chest you got to witness the best and
worst of society you know what else
built character though chainsawing
locust
i do know that feeling i've done that a
couple times holy [ __ ] when you when
that chainsaw comes out on gears i think
that's like top 15 most satisfying like
experiences as a human
number 15.
[Music]
that's why that game was so
revolutionary yeah is it that yeah just
that one mechanic was so new and unheard
of the gore in that game was next level
you had the nasher shotgun
that was just [ __ ] chunk people out
it was so good it was so satisfying oh
and the
sound when you beheaded someone it was
like
oh that i have been saying that for
years because people like years of war
two and three were better i'm like no
they were not here's where one had that
beautifully pop sound on like a headshot
so clean so good so satisfying whoever
did the sound design for that he should
be doing asmr he'd make a kick
or she you know whoever it is dying
locust asmr
if he did that on tick tock he'd have
every dude like from every generation on
there like dude time to go to bed
[Laughter]
gears was not i feel like at least
because i didn't play a ton of
controller games but so me coming into
it was just horrible but i felt like
being good at gears it was not easy you
know like even with like aim assist i
felt like it was still mechanically kind
of a tough game yeah no that was
definitely a game that separate boys
from men because it was just so
different yeah it was a third person
game where you were constantly bouncing
from cover and you could like bounce off
of things so quickly it just changed the
way you'd like approach a fight the [ __ ]
was it had a lot of layers that i mean
that's where nick merks actually got his
start too he used to be a pro gears
player got it so it bred some good
gamers
huh i'm trying to think of another
popular third person shooter like that
before then most people played halo
first person didn't they yeah halo's
first person counter-strike was also big
during yeah i played a lot of cs first
person yeah there really wasn't any like
big third-person shooters it's become
kind of the trend now thanks to
fortnight yeah up until then it was
really just kind of gears that was like
your competitive third person like
action shooter which is it like
interesting to think about you'd think
that after the successive gears like
more game developers might have been
like oh
maybe third person is the way did you
did you play a lot of cs back then not
back then i played cs a lot when i got
to well actually like senior year of
high school yeah i think that's when cs
go came out i played a lot of cs go
before then i played like a little bit
like a little bit of source a little 1.6
but i didn't get like really into it
until cs go cs go now is depressing
especially as like a millennial oh like
an aging old cringe lord yeah well it
was bad i can't keep up any more in
games like that i would just like i
would queue up and there'd be like dudes
who are very clearly like in their late
20s early 30s and like they still behave
the same you know like
you know like you get clapped and then
they're like they're just dropping slurs
and they're like dude you're so [ __ ]
bad i'm like
start a family no but they do they have
it it's true yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know when we were young we would make
fun of the dudes that had kids yeah like
what are you doing bro get off we're
like 16 like we're supposed to be doing
this what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
those dudes took it and now like when
they were there when they were they were
18 they're like i'm never gonna stop
playing cs dude it's for [ __ ] life
what gets me is just getting old man
just getting absolutely slammed by
everyone in the games i play now does
not feel good yeah i'm like damn how old
are you 27 so we're getting up there
getting up there yeah no 27 you
definitely don't have the hand eye like
you used to no
it is it is gone every time i try and
play it's so embarrassing especially if
i'm streaming and i have to think of so
many excuses for what's going on like
hands are cold my hands are all slippery
slipping off the controller took a
shower recently now i'm a little pruned
up
i will i will say the only game that i
think i could still be decent at is
quake or like a quake style game oh but
you should try split gate because i'm
actually still pretty good at that
because it's an arena shooter yeah old
school arena shooter yeah see that's
where i feel like
we can get the young guys because they
yes they don't understand arena shooters
they don't understand fast-paced action
yeah dude like that's what that's what
gaming used to be now it's all kind of
slowed down a little bit 100 when we get
into like a like a thunderdome like a
quake split gate style thing i i feel
like older people go wild [ __ ] out of
here dude i had a when quake 4 came out
i was like one of the few competitive
players online i was in this league i
was in cal and i was like doing well and
but i didn't realize that i was like the
only teenager and all the dudes in the
league on the east and central like
divisions
were like [ __ ] 30 year olds that
played quake their whole life so when i
got to like the final tournament bracket
all my friends were like dude you might
like take it all away that's sick and
first round i ran into
some dude who like had like an extensive
like quake like record online i only got
one kill which was like i dropped a
grenade through a portal and he ran into
it and like
there was like a live chat like
streaming it like going crazy then after
that this kid [ __ ] wasted me like so
brutal
that's unfortunate my friends did not
text me after that like i was just like
i just sat in silence after i got washed
online and i just had to have dinner
like
cold ass bed bath and beyonce yeah the
cold ass chicken dinner like damn i
probably should have did my homework
that was embarrassing have you ever won
like a gaming tournament or anything
there there was one like local land
tournament where me and my friends we we
got like kind of decent like a decent
way through and then yeah we just ran
into like some
[ __ ] like guys in like their mid-20s
that were at peak performance and again
just wasted us so do you get hit up to
be in any game tournaments just because
of twitch well yeah those are just like
the funsies one though like i've never
been competitively viable at any game
ever yeah cody have you ever when you
were diving were you playing pro gears
of war tournaments online
i would really care about my rank yeah
for sure but they kept tracking gears
they had like an entire leaderboard it's
funny like those years
of like 2006
to i don't know if it'd even be that
early but you know i remember everyone
always talk about like how crazy it was
like in korea you could be like a pro
starcraft player you know and
professional counter strike was just
becoming a thing but i think it was like
09 2010 sometimes like my friends would
get like we should get high and then
we just stay up till four in the morning
and watch these like pro starcraft
players it's a weird period of life i
remember being so impressed by the
production and it it's kind of wild how
long it took for us to like catch up
they they really like adopted the
esports thing super early like brood
wars and all that they went hard yeah
what was that
mlg was a thing but like only kind of
you know like it didn't there wasn't
money in it if you competed in the mlg
you just lose money like your parents
just hate you you're just draining their
bank account to travel there
they'd sometimes get on sportscenter
when it was halo 2. so you'd have like
walshy play occasionally dude yeah i
remember this
you'd have the whole middle school
pumping their fists like oh my god
they're gaming for a career this is
[ __ ] nuts what would they play halo
mainly oh yeah it's pretty much only
halo like even there was gears of war
pro scene but it was mainly just
something called game battles so just a
bunch of sweaty
nerds playing each other for the sake of
a website score yeah there was one like
tournament called the cpl
which is i think based off of like the
cat like cow league which was like i
think one of the most popular
online leagues in like the early 2000s
but i want to say the guy who ran cpl uh
which is like also a horrible acronym
like [ __ ] child pornography
atlanta i don't know
[Music]
the league of cp uh i think he went to
jail or something for like embezzling
money i thought you were gonna say four
child no i mean that would have been so
poor i know right yeah
no it was like he uh
because i remember the tournament fee
was something kind of nominal it was
like 125 bucks or like per person i
think he just had like a ton of people
sign up and then just never put on the
event one year
the old rug poll yeah
that was the first nft thinking you were
going to participate in a gaming league